good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a beautiful
Wednesday here in New York City I hope
it's beautiful wherever you are
hey Claud hi you durn good morning
everyone
I hope you're having a split into
beautiful day I hope so too well the
day's just starting for us so far so
good I have a nice view out my window it
looks chipper I think I'm going to leave
the house today it's been about four
days I was zooming with my friends last
night and I straight up looks like a
mole woman like so pale my eyes are just
like in the back of my head I need some
sunlight it's time um you know I haven't
gotten that itch I haven't left my house
in probably over a week I did walk Theo
twice over the weekend so I guess that
counts but um Ben's really been taking
the brunt of the walks and I've just
been really enjoying um quarantine this
week I have a whole new lease on life
I'm being very productive I started a
you know home project I don't know if
you saw my tick tock I'm gonna be
documenting the process on my tick-tock
job I'm just as well you were like
organizing makeup and stuff but why so
much bad news a lot of time here at my
my desk I guess you could call it but
it's really just my vanity for my makeup
I don't work well on a desk that I get
my most work done when I'm laying in bed
or like on the couch so but this space
has just been really cluttered up with
just tons of like hair and makeup stuff
and then also on my podcasting equipment
so I ordered a brand new vanity from
impressions vanity which is like the
best vanity company and I'm going to
change out my desk but before that I
needed so I clean up get rid of products
had a lot of expired makeup my like
bulbs on my vanity light we're so dusty
so I started phase one of the project
my vanity doesn't come till next week so
the project unfortunately has to be put
on hold until then but it's just
exciting to have something to look
forward to which vanity did you get
because I went through this a few months
ago we used to have the same vanity the
one that you have now is the one that I
used to have it was teeny tiny so I went
to impression vanity and I ordered a
big-ass new vanity it's like way too big
for the space and you know what like
it's still cluttered it's like more
space more problems yes so the desk that
I got doesn't have that much more
storage but this one that I have not
only if I had it for too long it's an
actual piece of [ __ ] like you know you
had it it's made
yeah Wadley it's so thin like you could
literally carry it on your index finger
and spin it like a basketball that's how
light it is
it's just not really um up to par with
my needs so well the one that I got is
literally the exact same shape the exact
same design it just has a glass top and
I have oh it doesn't only have two
drawers yeah it has one drawer oh but
then with the like lucite gnomes is that
what you have yep one drawer two knobs
glass-top that is so funny and I also
got because I needed more storage I got
the impression vanity set of drawers
that matches the vanity the hole is on
backwards ordering it won't come till
June so I was like I need more drawers
but more importantly I need this do not
look ugly and I'm very limited this
corner of my bedroom has 32 inches of
wall and then that vanity that we both
got is 31.5 inches it's like the only
vanity that works so even though it
looks the same it's just like a much
prettier version like this desk was
actually fifty dollars and it looks like
it yeah ooh voice cracked I was
emotional like saying goodbye my old
vanity I will say that I went down the
same journey as you this glass top one
is much more massive than the other one
and for me it's like a little too
massive and I did all the measurements
so I don't know where I went wrong and
it's just like juts out it's so ugly but
you know what that's actually a great
idea to like reorganize I have all this
storage and stuff for my makeup but then
all my makeup sits on top of my vanity
and I don't go into the drawers so like
there's got to be a better way there's
you gotta kick it up see simple and
there's got an honest thing doing a home
project Tech Talk really inspired me
because you know what you watch on tick
tock dictates to algorithm for your for
you page so I've really been gravitating
towards like a lot of people like
turning their back patio into a summer
Oasis cleaning out my pool and I love
following along they do like eight part
series and I got jealous so even though
I don't like how the back patio
unfortunately I'm limited to this corner
of my bedroom but it's the one that I
like the least like I really like how I
decorated my bedroom I feel like it's
really I did a very good job at he'd
spend a lot of money but everything
looks really like classy everything from
Wayfarer but this corner just looks like
a different part like a different house
someone else lives here so I'm excited
to to get started on my
unfortunately I'm going to have to set
up the vanity myself where I would
normally get like a handy or a thumbtack
to do it um but I don't even know if
those websites are like taking people
and I don't really want to have someone
come into the house so it's gonna be me
and then that's also a fun project I'm
excited for you and now I'm feeling
inspired I should have a big cleaning
day because I don't really have like any
other major plans like I always do
actually I think I'm going on a socially
distant walk if you would like to come
for a slice of pizza
hmm sounds like a last-minute invitation
but I'll see what I can do I think you
should come let's get a great slice of
pizza I mean you do make a compelling
case when it comes to pizza and I'm
never one to turn down a meal I'm
actually just very busy I have a lot of
projects you know secret projects
special projects it's really annoying
to be that person but I think a lot of
people like already know what it is and
I've been working on quarantine like
quarantine has actually been a blessing
I don't know if I would have been able
to devote so much time to this specific
project and its really turning out way
better than I thought it and I just
think a lot of people are gonna be
excited about it and you don't want to
share any additional information even
though people might already know what it
is no I can't I've been strictly ordered
by the big man upstairs everyone well
that's that on that then um what did i
do yesterday since I last saw you guys I
feel like I had such a busy day but I
guess I didn't well that's okay cuz we
have a busy episode we have dere
toasters we're gonna recap Vanderpump
rules and then all the other TV which I
finished never have I ever and I have so
many thoughts like my Monday school oh
good you like it oh my god the second
half of the show was spectacular like I
got why people were obsessed with it I
still don't like the main actress
especially because she has a very
emotional ending and she's just not
equipped with the talents um to act in
that way like she was just really giving
me community theater vibes but it was
good I did have one problem with the
show that I know a lot of people did but
we'll talk about it after we talk by
venom from rules and then we'll do deer
toaster so if you want you I think we
could just die right it I'm pretty yeah
I think so I'm off the deep end watch as
I dive into the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast it
okay first story is a very happy story
it's a story that a lot of
people have been following but we
haven't really discussed here on the
toast and I've been like following it
personally but now we have some good
news to share because Nick Cordero has
woken up from his coma after his cattle
with coronavirus after battling
coronavirus for more than a month in
intensive care Broadway actor Nick
Cordero has woken up from a medically
induced coma his wife Amanda cludes made
the announcement on her Instagram story
while holding their son Elvis quote guys
we might have to change our hashtag to
hash tag code rocky because Nick dad is
awake she said code rocky is a term that
medical professionals used to indicate
when current enviros patients are on
their way to a full recovery
Lutz had previously been using the
hashtag wake up Nick to spread the word
about Cordero's condition and show
support for him via social media she
also gave more updates regarding his
condition is in a separate post her
Instagram story stating that he is still
weak but following verbal commands quote
he's extremely weak so weak that he
can't close his mouth but he is
following commands which means Mental
Status is coming back is so great this
is such a great update to a story that
has really um captured a lot of people's
hearts and interest and his wife Amanda
has been like updating everyone along
the way and I'm so happy for this
positive turn of events I think this was
like the good news that we all needed
right now yeah like I've been following
along as well with her Instagram stories
and to be honest like I don't know if
that would be as positive as she's been
this entire time like through the highs
and the lows and she's really just like
a beacon of hope and she's been so
positive this whole time so I'm just
really happy that she got a win because
she made it and I'm really really happy
this is just excellent news yeah this is
excellent news and I feel like a lot of
toasters and just people are very
interested in this story so we just
wanted to share a good update obviously
has a long road to recovery but this is
a major major win so Peter hopefully you
can just be soon and their family can be
together because their kid is so cute
and there's such cute family and well
wishes this is revolution mama this is
wonderful wonderful okay speaking of
Broadway this next story is like
interesting and taking the just taking
the news world by storm it's really the
big story of the day I would think and
it's really [ __ ] random it's not a
story but I just wanted to put it out
there in case
there's like a major rumor going around
that Khloe Kardashian is pregnant again
she's trending on Twitter but there's
like one fake article written about it
so it's not by any means confirmed i jus
want to put it out there in case people
think it's true like you heard it on the
chest you know yeah um I don't want to
put it out there like let her do her
thing
yeah I'm just saying people like why
would there be any rumors because she's
at home quarantine too like what would
someone know or have seen other than the
lies that they've started on their fake
website just sending us out there no
it's not out there
we're prematurely on Twitter she's
trying on Twitter I think everyone's
just like one sad for her um it's just
wishful thinking but let her do it on
her own time if she is or she is it yeah
okay but here's the exciting story
Hamilton has had a change of course
Disney sets of July third streaming
release for 75 million dollar lin-manuel
Miranda musical okay Hamilton the
musical original cast on Broadway is
coming to Disney Plus in July July 3rd
right in time for Independence Day it
was supposed to come out in over a year
from now um but they bumped it up
because they know that we need the
content and I'm actually so excited
because I never got to see Hamilton and
I now I want to see it but it's not the
original cast anymore so it's like it's
not the same um now like I love a movie
musical like this is just exactly the
way that I needed to consume Hamilton
there are so many good things about this
like one a streaming service is taking
note and pushing up their content thank
you it only took you two months second I
never saw Hamilton either people were
telling you like you got to see it and I
never got to see it and then by the time
I had time to see it it was not with the
original cast and I just like wasn't
interested so that's fabulous - this
gives me hope that there could be
similar projects in the works like maybe
a fence kottdeer I'm enhancing it's the
same type of vibe where it's like you
got to go see Darren Hanson and it's
good no matter what but like it's really
spectacular we've been flat so this is
just giving any hope on all frontiers
and I'm just glad that someone is
listening to us yeah someone by the name
of Robert Iger actually because until
he's Disney executive chairman and like
his whole like taking a step back was
like a long month long process so he's
still the man in charge I think okay for
now
um but he and lin-manuel Miranda just
announced on Good Morning America this
bump in the schedule which is very
exciting
also when Hamilton was on Broadway with
the original cast it was impossible to
get tickets like you had to be like a
Broadway theater sleuth you know knowing
people and they were so expensive so
like this is just this is a win for
everyone and you know this is especially
a win for Broadway because Hamilton was
amazing but it was just like so
inaccessible and a true Broadway lovers
like kids who loved Robert like didn't
even get to see it because it was just
too unattainable so they're bringing it
to the masses this is a win for Hamilton
but it's really a win for Broadway and
this is fabulous I mean I'll never
forgive lin-manuel for not only stealing
two hundred dollars for me but also I'm
making the atrocity that was Mary
Poppins but to me this is a check in his
column like he he's working his way back
into my heart yeah he definitely has a
lot of pros and cons I would say and I
feel like because his biggest
accomplishment yet is Hamilton like that
like he changed the world I will
officially make my verdict after I've
seen it yeah yeah I've never even seen
it I know that one song because they did
a remix of a song from Evan Hanson where
Lymon Lomer and Ben Platt sang together
so I know one song apparently the music
is phenomenal and I am definitely going
to watch it I know a few of the songs
one because Kelly Clarkson did a cover
up it's quiet downtown and it's so
fabulous and then also musical Monday
every week Nick would play about one
Hamilton song so I'm pretty familiar I
like the one about um the one about the
girl getting married
I don't know anyways you do you like
staying Broadway shows when you know the
music before or do you want to be like
genuinely surprised no so if I same was
like movie musicals even what even when
greatest showmen came out and I knew I
was so excited to see it like it was
gonna change my life I would not listen
to the soundtrack before because first
of all it gives away like spoilers about
the story and everything just makes
sense in the context of the story like
even if I had listened to the dear I've
enhanced it and soundtrack before and
like they're talking about raising like
18 million followers or whatever like in
the middle like there's conversation in
the middle of the songs like you need to
see it in
context I think aside from like the
waiting through the windows like the big
pop anthem from each show like to listen
right on track it's like it's like
listening to an audiobook of the show I
I listen to a few songs from Evan Hanson
before I actually saw it and the one
that I really knew backwards and
forwards was waiting through a window
and it's such a powerful moment in this
in the show and I was actually so glad
that I knew it I just that moment is
like it's the culmination of everything
I think it's right before intermission
and it was just so powerful and he did
such a good job acting and singing that
I was actually really glad that I knew
it but normally I tend to agree with you
because if we list into a Broadway
soundtrack they literally leave the
monologue in and it totally spoils it
yeah I also like when I know one of the
big songs that's exciting but I don't
want to listen to the soundtrack is how
I feel so are we gonna get like a new
soundtrack with the same songs from this
version or it's gonna be the same I
think will be the same because it's
still original cast and that's what the
soundtrack is um so I think it would be
the same unless I mean you never know
they probably will sell a different
version right well I hope the promo they
do like kind of what I'm the greatest
showman did like and have traditional
pop stars and singers and artists do
their own versions I love that they did
that already and that's how by Kelly
Clarkson is on it's quiet downtown but
then I'm excited after I see Hamilton to
listen to that reimagined album I have
so much content waiting for me ya know
this is just this is great for music
lovers for Broadway lovers for Disney
lovers of a really wonderful thing thank
you Bob Iger once again hope your
daughter is listening okay next story
cameran Eubanks is not returning to
southern charm I heard this announcement
is so strange because it happened on
Instagram yes so she posted a photo
standing with her co-star Patricia all
xual and other friends with the caption
remember going out to you with friends
can't wait until we can do it again when
a fan commented missing the show when
are you returning she responded I will
not be returning so she didn't even make
a dedicated Instagram post she just
responded to a fan which is kind of
weird yeah ya know the way that it was
announced was weird but now just
thinking about it like I'm kind of down
for her not to be on she was in just
such a
totally different place for the last two
seasons and it just didn't make sense
that she was on the show anymore and she
was like actually starting to bother me
because I didn't agree with anything she
was saying yeah she just kind of outgrew
the show and last season was all about
you know her getting her groove back and
drinking but that can't be every season
and now the show has really become so
much like tom foolery and drinking and
single people and cut and it's just like
she's above it honestly um and so I
understand this decision for her and I I
accept it
yeah I think it's I think it's the right
move and but it is the first except for
Thomas it's like a first major departure
from southern charm for the most part
most of the cast members have been there
since the beginning um obviously with
the exception of Thomas but that really
wasn't much of a choice cuz he was you
know like go in jail um I think that
this is interesting I wonder what we'll
get I don't think lost we lost Landon
well she was not from the first season
she came in like three seasons in right
she like came on her boat and then she
was like living in LA married to a
producer yeah I think she came in the
second season and I was just like not
even like excited about her and then
also Whitney has dipped in and out yeah
yeah because he's also a producer so
he's like full-time in the show but not
really on the show yeah and I think
that's best for him yeah he's not my
favorite by any means I will miss
Cameron I loved her um but you know all
good things must come to an end
sometimes do you think that um a lot
Eliza is coming back I liked her she's
had it like a lot of personal
developments I think she's engaged not
to the guys on the show who I when is it
coming back it usually airs in the
spring but I haven't even seen a trailer
no everything is so delayed and weird
but we didn't really talk about The Real
Housewives of Atlanta reunion we had
spoken that they were gonna do at the
assume and be like said negative things
about it I just have to say it was very
well done like they obviously sent
equipment to everyone because it was not
zoom it was not iPhone or MacBook it was
like good enough for TV and everyone
looked really fabulous and they still
brought that level
from like the tips off yes I saw Clips
it was oh it was good it was good I'm
glad because we're getting a lot of more
virtual reunions Vanderpump rules filmed
I guess next week is the season finale
which means the reunion is in two weeks
which is insane there was no season
there was nothing that happened we'll
get into it but also at I mean I feel
like Real Housewives of New York in
Beverly Hills like might still be in the
realm of virtual reunions so yeah see
well I I'm really glad that they were
able to pull out all the stops that
bodes well for every other show when
they said that um it was gonna be the
season finale of Vanderpump rules next
week I was genuinely like relieved
having to turn it on hundred-percent
unenjoyable and like having to even
recap it it's just like you're recapping
like a farce
especially now like what we know about
Jeana and if you watch last night's
episode through the lens of like rooting
for scheana she was literally not on it
you know we'll talk about it in the
recap but I have a lot to say about
scheana remind me okay next up Zayn
Malik and Gigi Hadid are isolating in a
bucolic Pennsylvania splendor um
the world's most beautiful parents to be
are isolating together on Zane's farm in
Pennsylvania
Yolanda Gigi's mom also has a farm
nearby where she's been busy making
essential oils in Jin and he reportedly
bought the farm on her advice the former
One Direction heartthrob revealed in
2018 that he grows crops of tomatoes
cucumbers and cherries at the property
saying that he likes to do a lot of farm
work and ride his ATV he added that he
doesn't work well in group situations
with people staring at him oh well in
group situations so I'm I assume they
were all isolating on Yolanda's farm but
now to hear that they actually have
their own farm tremon just down the road
that you'll want to suggest they buy
like this is such a beautiful really
bucolic setting for the quarantine for
the Hadean Alex yeah and I actually love
a bucolic setting love's what's up
garlic um it's like you know just a
descriptive word of the Sun it's a word
of a city then
to the pleasant aspects of the
countryside and country life God so we
need that's what we need um this is
lovely honestly it's a great way to
spend quarantine like um on a lot of
property with like family right down the
road but it's also a really ideal way to
spend your pregnancy like out in the
land the family nearby
I'm kind of jealous I'm beyond jealous
like that's my new um personality trait
it's jealousy um it's just like looking
at everyone's homes and pools and farm
tremens and backyards and patios and
outdoor fire pits and being jealous on
watch repens ID last night um and he was
asking James and Raquel like how they
were quarantined and she's like I'm so
jealous of all my friends who have pools
like we are stuck in our apartment and
Tom and Ariana we're on also and I glad
the new house and then the pool and I
was totally feeling like oh um I hate to
be like the annoying person and asking
this question but it is kind of
pertinent because of quarantine did they
mention anything about getting furniture
in their house do they have hunger so I
really watched the first three minutes
of the episode but they were positioned
I believe in their kitchen with their
main living room in the background and
it did look like there was a rug a couch
and ottoman a table so I don't know if
the whole house is done and it's
definitely been put on pause since
quarantine but what we're watching now
is over a year ago so I have to imagine
it's for the most part furnished yeah
cuz he doesn't bother me on the show
that they don't have furniture but like
if you were in quarantine in an empty
house like that wouldn't not the idea it
doesn't bother me either and I totally
get one Arianna gets annoyed about it's
like that's the one thing you're gonna
come at her for like consistently like
please shut up yeah but you know what if
you don't have furniture and your
friends who have furniture are throwing
a party like don't throw a competing
party where people don't have it I mean
that's a totally different conversation
which will talk to you but they did take
care you know and what Lila said was was
harsh was way harsh tie that she does
want to go to a frat house and sit on
the floor and um house it doesn't have
furniture but I felt it to my core when
watching the two parties back and forth
like twerking asses in the air and then
a lovely handmade burger by Britney yeah
and they had the side and they had a bar
and bartenders and like even though
obviously
Ariana and Tom's party won because it
was cooler and more fun like Jackson
Britney like really wanted to do
something nice for everyone and like
make a
nice party and they just all shot all
over it and they just like made me sad
also like Jackson Burnie are married Jax
is almost 40 like that was an
appropriate party for them right and
like obviously they were a little more
choosy about who they made it yeah well
we'll get into it on the next story
that's brought to you by noon getting in
shape doesn't have to be about losing a
specific amount of weight or a magical
member on the scale it's about building
healthier habits and feeling better
about yourself it's fitting into your
favorite pair of jeans is your goal
great but there are many reasons why you
might want to practice self-care and
every person is different
new is that habits changing solution
that helps users learn and develop new
relationships with food your
personalized courses it's completely in
psychology so Newton teaches you why you
do the things you do and it empowers you
with the tools you need to break bad
habits and replace them with better ones
Noom is not a diet it is an easy and
healthy and easy to stick to way of life
no food is considered good bad or off
limits on noon they just teach you
moderation and it can be used in
conjunction with many preexisting
popular diets if you want Noom doesn't
tell you what to do or what not to do it
simply teaches you to look inside your
own mind and make better decisions for
yourself it one of the biggest and most
accurate food database is available that
lets you track meal habits visualize
portion sizes and see calorie density
other glands near humans have you
attacked there was no shaming just chips
to help you get back on track tomorrow
then has been um using the new map
because he's unlike this whole new kick
and he's been like measuring out all his
food we've got a food scale he said
looking for all the measuring cups and
like what do you need tablespoon for
he's like I gotta get the olive oil um
and so Noom having such a big database
has been really helpful for him Troy
track even like the tiny minuscule
things that he eats from brands you've
never heard of like they're always in
the new database which is exciting for
him yeah I've been using new because
I've been on it like a getting serious
about back on my diet just cuz like when
the world opens up like I want to be
ready for the world and they really make
it so easy and it's it's just like a
positive approach to dieting and I'm
very grateful for our friends at noon
right now you don't have to change it
all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
today at noon and oom calm fresh toast
what do you have to lose visit noon
dot-com slash toasts to start your trial
today that's n OH
m.com / toast okay fizz and final story
is a little is news because uber has
reportedly been in talks with the food
delivery giant GrubHub about a potential
takeover the negotiations are said to be
continuing and not a done deal but if
the two companies come to an agreement
it would amount to a major consolidation
of the delivery industry which has
become essential to many people in the
pandemic so GrubHub is gonna acquire
overeats know uber is gonna acquire
GrubHub wait that's crazy
Gribbs a huge company they also own
seamless but ubers a bigger cut like
uber eats you seem small but uber itself
is a massive company I guess yeah that's
kind of crazy I mean to me it's so
frustrating all the different apps
because all of them have positives and
negatives it's like sometimes the
restaurant you want is on a different
app but you prefer to use the other app
because it's quicker you know so if they
really all do the wonderful platforms
like uber eats seamless GrubHub door -
like they were all like one big
conglomerate like that would actually be
helpful for me I don't know they each
have their own little pizzazz I really
use like every single one of them for
one thing or another
um and I'm sure at the end of the day
they all do the same thing but they have
their own specialness yeah I like it to
be honest it's really changed the game
because they we're the first platform
that really provided like high quality
photos of all the food and now I see
that like happening on almost every
platform like I use caviar and even
seamless now has gotten into like the
fancy photos but new breeds really was
the first one to do it and it's so
helpful yeah it is helpful but there's
also our little misleading like
everything looks fabulous even if you've
seen the restaurant like in the street
and you know that it's not a fabulous
place yeah maybe I just like really have
a soft spot in my heart for uber II it's
because of their partnership with
McDonald's
oh no I absolutely love Ober eats
because everything looks fabulous but
it's just misleading like seeing this
makes everything look like a pile of dog
[ __ ] whether it is dog [ __ ] or its
five-star like they just have a way
about them that makes everything look
like one-star but they also have the
most the biggest database of restaurants
like I don't know about other cities but
in New York like if you
in a five-mile radius like there are
let's say there's 20 restaurants on
ubereats there's a hundred on seamless
oh I've never compared to contrasted but
there's like I just have my favorite
restaurants that I deliver from and then
I know which place um does it best but I
will say now that we're on the topic
something that used to bother me that I
don't really order from there anymore
right now but I will probably eventually
um by Chloe if anyone that by Chloe Corp
is listening like when you order a salad
um it doesn't give you the option like
to leave a note or to do no olives like
they let you do no chickpeas no
cucumbers are like no federer whatever
but like what about no olives like
that's a really controversial vegetable
and like it's very flavorful and if you
don't like it it could ruin your salad
potentially and also you need to make it
easier to do add-ons of Italian
meatballs in this specifically in the
Greek salad that's what I like to order
or can I get a side of Italian meatballs
because otherwise I have to order an
Italian sub just to eat the meatballs
out of the sub and they're not even
flavoured the way that I like so um
that's just my personal gripe of the day
if that could be arranged
I'm glad you got that off your chest
hopefully this podcast lands on the
right person's desk I mean as Polly
received
crazier things have happened we've asked
for crazier things like this isn't even
that crazy no I mean and our podcast has
reached the ears of crazier people hello
my high school English teacher right so
like I know for a fact that someone at
by Chloe Corp listens to this and I'm
just like I'm just gonna make the most
of my opportunities yeah I love like
using this platform that we have built
to my advantage like if you work at the
lottery can you send me a winning ticket
Thanks yeah I don't know I don't know if
like that works that way but but you
know just keep shooting your shot I will
never stop never okay let's get into TV
recaps Vanderpump rules yeah it was
actually a better episode than usual my
bar has really been lowered since this
new season um and I found myself just
really rooting for the Jackson Britney
party like maybe that's just because I'm
their friend and that's the vibe that I
got I wonder like it
they know any of the cast like how would
I choose sides but to be honest like I
get that Jax is everyone's mad at Jax
and he's very clearly going through
something that he can't really describe
like Stassi said it best when she said
it looks like he's losing his mind on
between all of us like crazy Instagram
stories I do feel like editing was
really pushing that narrative but like
Jax is crazy like maybe it wasn't as
crazy in person now that I know what I
know about the editing like I just I'm
watching the show through a more
critical eye um I'm just like I don't
know I really fell for it nee I felt
like the group was really like lumping
her and Jax together and even though
they're married I just firmly believe
like you should be held accountable for
your own actions and your own actions
only like I don't feel like you should
have to answer for anyone else even if
it is your husband and throwing a
competing party like that was mean and
when Ariana and Brittany were folding
clothes for Covenant House with Lisa
Vanderpump I just felt like Ariana was
kind of being rude yeah okay a bunch of
things first of all them starting every
clip back from commercials with Jax's
stories about working out like I think
they thought they were being like crafty
and clever and like integrating social
media in an interesting way but it was
god-awful and not interesting and I
don't give a flying [ __ ] like you want
to incorporate social media into the
show show all the stories and videos
from stassi's engagement party that
Kristen had to watch but wasn't there
for like [ __ ] like there are so many
different ways to do it in like us
continuing to see Jax at the gym like
hammering this point home I think they
were trying to take a comedic angle with
that it wasn't funny it was just
annoying
and they used one of the clips
completely out of context like when Jax
was like I'm putting my ring back on
they made it seem like that was a part
of the conversation that like him and
Brittany we're having trouble and like
she thought he might be cheating when in
reality I remember watching those
Instagram stories and he was speaking
about a paparazzi picture of him not
wearing his ring it was like Jax teller
started not wearing his ring and he was
speaking directly to that being like I'm
actually putting my ring back on I was
just working out and they just use that
out of context to make it seem like him
and Brittany we're actually having those
types of conversations yeah and so when
it comes to Jax and Brittany and like
the friendships and I understand that
like when people are mad at Jax like
obviously you're a couple your package
shuo but like Jax is probably the most
controversial one of the group and
Brittany is the most beloved so I do
think that those two things should
cancel each other
and people should just come to their
party because you don't want to go
because of Jax but you want to go
because of Britney and like the fact
that people aren't the fact that like
Katie wouldn't go for Britney and like
Tom for Jax like I thought that that was
so egregious and then Katie in the tent
like pretending to give a [ __ ] about
Dana's love like I'm like what show am i
watching I feel like I just like stepped
into a different planet and there's like
this crossover that nobody asked for
yeah I mean in terms of the other people
have then went to Tom and Ariana's
because they were actually disinvited
from turning in Jax's so bad I
understand they were never invited to
Britney Jax's like Danica and Charlie
like Jax does not know these people and
I don't it wasn't him even James and
Raquel like
they weren't initially invited to Jax's
like that's fine the only people that I
really felt should have been at Jax and
Britney's were Tom and Katie completely
agree I honestly had to choose between I
probably would have went to Brittany and
Jax it's like all the people I would
like Lala Stassi like I would have
wanted to be at that party even though
they made it seem like it was the losery
party but Charlie was bothering me so
much this episode like when she was at
the party she was like grandpa Jack does
that I wouldn't want to be at his party
like good [ __ ] you weren't [ __ ]
invited yeah she is annoying it's just
like classic case of freshmen for
seniors and like we are the seniors
which is why we gravitate towards Stassi
Jax the oh geez and voila wherever Lala
goes is with a place to be yeah and I
thought it was interesting that Bret
went to the other party probably cuz he
just like didn't wanna run into max and
I just wish Dana was out the other party
because I love her but I'm [ __ ] done
with Bret like one day we're sitting at
that meal he was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me first of all maybe you have
feelings for hurts like shouted at the
table is so embarrassing first of all
second of all you do like you just went
on a date and made out like I don't
understand the logic of a boy who's like
I took a girl out onto day to be made
out to times why does she think I like
her I don't know I have no idea Dana
should have been at Jax's party that was
the only thing missing her comedy was
funny yeah it was my dad's not all that
like that was funny yeah I liked it I
mean it takes massive cojones to perform
in front of your new friends your new
reality TV cast members and have the
camera
there and you know and we know editing
does what they want they could have
chosen her worst jokes and completely
made her look like a fool but she took
that that risk and care for it and she
looked so cute in her blazer I just like
felt bad for her at that meal afterwards
and when Sheena showed up um it's hard
because editing like makes you want to
hate scheana but I was watching it
through the sons like let's say someone
has it out for scheana like the second
she walks and they play this like creepy
music when it's like she Neiman do
anything and she just walked in and I
saw them cutting a lot between like um
things that she said that were obviously
a different part of a conversation I'm
just like more critical now and I just
feel bad for and she like was totally
cut out of last night's episode like
whose party did you go to yeah also um
why didn't she nago to the comedy show
though yes that was strange I don't
maybe she wasn't motive no it seems like
everyone was invited and and why would
she be invited to the after party like
it seems like she was prioritizing other
things and like Dana was like that's
sucking like that's not that your friend
no that's right down the street and she
couldn't go I love how much Stassi like
respects Dana yeah but it's like all of
the oh geez have just chosen to like
raise Dana up you know and it's like
okay now it's not original for you to be
nice to Dana Katie right and I think
that like Stassi in a way is like
passing the baton on today man yeah yeah
I don't know what I'll be interesting
what happens next season this just is
like a weird limbo season and now with
all this stuff that's coming up out
about production um it's time for like a
revamp yeah I'm um I'm really just like
uh I'm excited about the new people like
I'm really and I don't even consider
them new but I really like James and
Raquel and I love that everyone is like
really seeing that he's changed on March
Evans IV said he's 11 months sober like
I love that but some of the new people
rugby the rugby so the wrong way like
Tanika and Charlie like Charlie when she
was waiting on Dana and bread at their
date like first of all that was just
weird to have a friend wait on you and
she was just like really overstaying her
welcome like talking and it's like
they're on a date yeah it looks like
next week is like a good episode
obviously it's the season finale but it
looks like you know what we used to get
in one episode from man or pump worlds
like everyone's fighting Danica's coming
for like Sheena
Vegas and I'm actually looking forward
to that um but otherwise this season has
been a complete wash and I just want to
say like I totally love James and Raquel
Here I am saying it I love them I look
like I just I love them yeah I was
wondering um when Brittany came for
Katie saying that Ariana said the entire
second party was Katie's idea we never
get real clarity on whether or not that
was true okay thirty percent of each
episode these days is flashbacks and in
that moment I was like where's my
flashback I'll make my judgement right
here right now
and they didn't get it to us and like
that was [ __ ] that was so annoying
and you know what I'm not gonna go back
and watch the other episode but then
someone messaged me cuz I put this on my
story and they said basically it was
Tom's idea Tom Sandoval and Katie was
like oh my god yes that would be
hilarious whatever yeah if I remember
correctly it wasn't necessarily her idea
but she was really the one encouraging
it hundred percent and that is so [ __ ]
up also when Shay Ariana was talking to
Kristen and Carter who I guess we're
back together and now like party B has
to pretend like we should we ship
whatever um and Kristen said that
scheana said that Stassi was making fun
of Ariana's house maybe we missed that
part but when what I saw that was Lala
who said all that stuff but I'm sure
that Stassi said something about Tom and
Ariana's house like it's not the it's
not the most evil thing in the world but
[ __ ] Ariana hopped the [ __ ] off after
that like literally saying it's not
knows [ __ ] think she always want to
pretend that she cares I mean like she
literally went off and she was drunk
obviously but that was a real window
into how much Ariana hates Stassi and
when she said that she liked copy Tina's
shoe closet I was just like you're
[ __ ] making fun of my house in your
two-bedroom partner when you turn the
other bedroom into a shoe closet cuz you
want a copy Sheena like that whole
[ __ ] like three seconds was fire like
literally fire-breathing dragon I know
but it aired now and Stassi has like
this massive new house that's stunning
with furniture and I'm sure she gives
two shits and the sponsorship from bear
paint like she's doing chest mine yeah
um but no but here's the thing it's like
if Stassi was making front of Ariana's
house and they're gonna show Chris and
telling Ariana and that like they should
have showed us the part where Stassi
made front of Ariana's house and I was
just reading and a lot of stuff about
this
editing is coming up like I've said on
page six today that also it was said
that like Bravo once a CMO to look like
heroes in the season and so that would
maybe explain why they didn't show
Stassi making fun of Ariana's house but
like just give us all of the story or
none of or move on from the storyline
but like these half stories it's just
not working
yeah before we even found out about this
production stuff it just felt like the
show was so over produced and
untrustworthy and now that we know all
of this it's even more not believable
yeah angry um okay um before we do dear
toasters I just want to talk about never
have I ever I finished the second half
of it and I absolutely loved it it was
so endearing and you then there's gonna
be a second season because it left on
like this kind of cliffhanger and I just
like loved it the boys are like loving
Debbie and it's it's a good show oh it's
not all you have to say except is just
about to turn my volume off oh no I
won't spoil anything it was it was
really good I do have one gripe that I
saw maybe I only felt that way because I
got a bunch of messages being like you
know a lot of the episodes especially
episode 7 were like really fat phobic
when the show is like so 2020 do you
know what I mean it's like it just
really checks a lot of boxes and that's
why it's so popular like Mindy Kaling
making an Indian actress like the main
character of a popular high school TV
show like that's never happened so I
really that's why a lot of people I
think were drawn to it just because it
is so different and finally like more
representation and there's just like one
fat character and it just like really
bothered me how it was like he was just
like a joke and like the butt of every
scene and he would like came into the
big sound was like I heard you guys give
win free stuff like it was just really
bothered me how like like that people
are just like not protected for him like
those types of like sensitivities Jenni
I mean yeah he was just like this cute
kid who was like always fat and eating
like a lazy piece of [ __ ] and it's like
are you kidding it was just so
disappointingly stereotypical and I get
that like fat people aren't necessarily
like a minority that I don't know it
just it really bothered me and I don't
know if it only bothered me because
people message me about it and then I
watched this character Eric who was by
no means even a main character he was
just like some kid at school I don't
know
I was so like rubbed the wrong way
because somebody put that in my brain
and I wanted to see it that way but it
was just like really disappointing
yeah that sounds disappointing yeah it
bothered me but other than that it was
really good job okay cool I'm adding it
to my list officially yes you like long
longer don't give up on it because in
the beginning I was like ready to stop
but last night and the episodes are 25
minutes so I needed something short like
that okay cool I'll be ready for dear
toasters yes your toasters is brought to
you by function of beauty we all need a
frustration bottles on bottles of hoppy
shampoo and conditioner piling up in
your bathroom each one promised to be
everything of the sort but they lied to
you you deserve better so try function
of beauty we don't even have the same
hair so why should we all use the same
shampoo and conditioner now we don't
have to do the function of beauty if
you're ready to live your best hair life
in 2020 then you need to try functional
beauty it is an Internet's top-rated
customized haircare brand with over
30,000 five-star customer reviews and
Counting whether you have curly or
straight hair naturally processed
function of beauty individually
formulates every bottle based on your
unique hair type style preference and
hair goals to begin the short for
question quiz and save 20% on your first
purchase go to function of beauty calm /
toast tell them about your hair you can
customize your formula by fragrance and
color and you can even go dive free or
free it's free the products are so
personalized your name is even printed
on the bottom plus function of beauty is
vegan and cruelty-free they never use
sulfates parabens flat plates mineral
oils or any other harmful ingredients to
get started right now I've got a
function of beauty calm / toast to take
your fourth part of your profile quiz
and save 20% on your first order don't
spend another minute in her misery go to
function of beauty calm / just to let
them know that we sent you again that's
function of beauty calm / toast love it
Einon get your function of e di love my
function of e I'm actually running low
um but I told you guys I got the colors
to match my bathroom and they smell like
eucalyptus and honestly I feel like I'm
always at the spa which is why I love
taking showers now um so I highly
recommend all right first up hit them
I'm writing about this to you guys
because I know you and your sisters are
so close and share special
my sisters and I are the same light we
are best friends I'm younger but one of
my older sisters just entered her 30s
and she has never been in a relationship
I'm almost positive she's still a virgin
she's so adamant about not me not
needing a man which I completely
respected admire nobody should ever need
a man but I'm concerned she's not gonna
find love or special connection because
she's not open to it at all when someone
asked her about her man status she says
she's just simply not dating do I let
her do this for potentially ever or
should i encourage her to get out there
get out there obviously the key was hard
right now but after all this is over I
don't see anything changing either this
has been years building up and it's
awkward that I'm so much younger than
him than her with way more relationship
experience I wouldn't be the best I
would want her to find someone one day
not to mention she would be the best mom
ever
what would you guys do if this is one of
you guys love you xoxo a sister Steve
okay this is so touchy and if it was one
of us and I think for everyone it's
different and like you know her better
but if this was one of us and I know my
sisters well and I know that ultimately
like all of us would want a relationship
and to be a mom and to have all of those
things and that even though we don't
need a man like it you want a family and
you just want that I would have like a
sit-down yeah I would have a sit-down
while also keeping in mind potential
sensitivities um because just hearing
this I feel like it might be possible
that she doesn't want a man she may be
she's gay like I would just keep those
types of possibilities in the back of
your mind while having a conversation
about that like maybe she just hasn't
wanted to talk about dating or hasn't
been dating because there's something
like eating her up inside and you should
lay the foundation of being like if
that's the case like we love you we
accept you like just not that that's
what's going on here but it's a very
possible scenario yeah I wouldn't sit
down with her and be like you need to
get married bah blah blah blah I would
come from a place of love obviously it
was like the people I don't know how
many other siblings you have or your
parents just like people who love her
and be like we love you we want the
absolute best for you like we are here
for you um but we also want to see you
find love and happiness and what can we
do to help you start on that journey um
and just coming it's just the way
the delivery is as important as the
message um but I think if it were us
which is what you're asking I'm not like
telling you what to do but if it were us
that is what I would do I would organize
like a family sit down and just like a
State of the Union and be like how are
things what's going on like you know
what are what and if she's not focused
on finding a relationship um what does
she focused on like where is she putting
all of her eggs in my basket and just
like you know moving some of those eggs
around into different baskets yeah
obviously what you say it's so important
but how you really all come at it is
also really important because it could
feel like she's being getting dumped on
and you don't want that because in the
Commerce stage becomes about something
else
yeah so no really delicate yeah but
sisters are sisters so sometimes you
have to say stuff that's not always like
the popular or easy thing to say but
you're all better off for it yet if you
didn't care you would just let her keep
doing what she's doing and not ever like
having these hard conversations but you
do it because you love her and you care
about her and like you want her to be
happy yeah okay this is our second and
final tear toasters again if you ever
want to write in two dear toasters the
email is dear toasters at gmail.com
we're talking everything from quarantine
to my husband secretly donates to a
sperm bank anything dear toasters my
roommate just doesn't understand this
whole sharing space during the work from
home days I typically work from my
bedroom because I'm a teacher and my
meetings are not nearly as often as her
corporate job and she's constantly on
the phone lately I've been trying to
work out in our shared space at the
counter and she has her desk set up
whenever I come out into the shared
space she immediately strikes up a
conversation I respond and then try to
kind of make it obvious that I have to
get back to work or that I'm busy and
can't chat she was not getting the sign
so I've been putting headphones in now
she will just talk louder and get closer
to me to make sure I can hear her today
she literally was asking me about baby
names and how many kids I want I would
put the headphones in and she would
continue to strike up a new conversation
I literally have been typing emails
while she talks and she would say are
you listening I'm so much less
productive in my bedroom but I have to
start strictly working there because I
can't take her constant conversations I
want to use the counter and set up my
own desk without having to dodge
conversations all day and I just mean
it'll irritable or is this a valid
problem signs tip toaster a valid
problem what is she doing honestly like
there's a million different ways you can
go about this but
this were me like even reading this I'm
becoming irate and I would just snap at
her like she's taught you're working
working she's talking to you talking to
you and you turn and you say what is you
doing you see I'm trying to work I would
never do this to you baby names can we
have this conversation over dinner like
why you always trying to disturb my
workflow like working from home is hard
enough like I think she needs to snap
the hell out of it like I I don't really
think like going in with kids and being
like could you please respect my space
like she's not a respectful person of
space like I would just whip my head and
be like shut the [ __ ] up yeah but I
would be careful how you snap her back
into shape because you have to live with
her and Quarantine you can't leave your
house so you don't want to make a fight
it's very possible that she thinks
you're coming into the living room from
your like quote-unquote office of the
bedroom because you don't have anything
to do but people don't respect
headphones like headphones aren't very
much a communication device like I'm
wearing a headphone that means I'm not
available for discussion so people who
don't respect the headphone rule are
social pariahs yeah I'm just like I'm
angry with her and honestly if you do
snap at her and she gets like you know
miffed about in doesn't talk to you for
a few days good right like that could be
just what your friendship and
relationship needs like a few days off
yeah like you could try and go to the
police you know I'm working but like I
feel like we're beyond this you put in
the headphones like you're very clearly
working and she very clearly doesn't
care and it's time to snappy oh yeah you
know what's funny is we've spoken a lot
about how difficult it might be to be in
quarantine with you know a boyfriend or
fiancé that you're like I'm easy about
or it could be great we haven't really
even touched on the relationship between
roommates like a lot of people live with
people just because they want someone
who they're not super close with so it
doesn't get weird and now you're like
stuck with the person roommate
situations are always like weird and
effy and i wonder how people are faring
in quarantine yeah I think a lot of
people who have roommates or I mean just
a lot of people are have gone home to
like their parents house in tribal so
there's not that many roommate
situations in the queue but there's
clearly some and the roommates need to
step off step off in the words of Kacey
Musgraves yep um with all your
negativity just Leia it's according to
anthem honestly
yeah you should just keep playing it on
repeat until she steps a guy you could
like create a playlist of like really
intentional songs maybe they get to her
and also like move [ __ ] get out the way
that's good yeah so if you guys
everybody hear from us please email do
toasters at gmail.com we always keep it
anonymous and that's our show thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up elbows I
guess anywhere podcast we found such
action stitcher public video I never
take a spot all the places where ever
you listen to find us no money just
leave a five star review I've had a
beautiful sunny that's where we are um I
actually realize what I'm gonna do right
now because I'm so excited the new
episode of mood drop today Morin is
interviewing JC Marie Smith who's a
fellow influencer who I just started
following recent leaks I found her on
take talk and like she is just
everything of the sort and Lauren like
was telling me how the conversation went
so well they talk a lot about like being
an influencer right now I mean I haven't
listened yet but I'm literally about to
the listen right now I'm so excited to
like hear two of my favorite influencers
chatting there's also a brand new
episode of caviar dreams tuna fish
budget with Margaret Joseph's and she
did to bomb [ __ ] episodes that's week
with Barbara Kay from Real Housewives of
New York and Melissa we're different
Housewives of New Jersey so it was like
a housewives fan dream they're all
available on iTunes or Spotify you can
follow chose news network for any and
all updates about all of our TNN shows
thank you guys for supporting that we
bring also this snatchler has a new
episode out and she's interviewing like
I guess the villain from listen to your
heart and she called me after and she's
like her heart and her mind she's
listening to her heart and it's been
changed so if you are watching that show
like it seems like this is the interview
to watch she's having the Leeanne Locken
experience that we had yes definitely so
I'm excited I'm gonna go hit up on
Mightyena and content today check it out
we will see you tomorrow bye